[Musik]
Abteilung 1
Deutschland
im Gleichschritt Arsch marschieren für
Deutschland Grundausbildung von 27
Rekrutinnen und Rekruten im
heimatschutzregiment Berlin für sieben
Monate haben sie sich bei der Bundeswehr
verpflichtet erst einmal warum bei dem
Überfall auf die Ukraine letztes Jahr
habe ich mir auch gedacht was wenn es
wirklich hier bei uns
ich möchte dieses Ohnmacht einfach nicht
haben und möchte im Ernstfall wirklich
verteidigen können
die Deutschen und das dienen das
Verhältnis ist heute ambivalent zeigt
eine Umfrage für Berlin direkt wenn
jemand zur Bundeswehr geht finden dass
82% der Befragten gut 10% nicht aber das
eigene Leben einsetzen um die Heimat zu
verteidigen dazu ist nur knapp jeder
zweite Deutsche bereit
ob ich ihn ob ich nicht hin ob ich
Ersatzdienst mache aber welchen Dienst
ich dem Gemeinwesen tue ist uns etwas
verlustig gegangen
es klappt ein Riss zwischen Bundeswehr
und Gesellschaft verstärkt wird das
Ganze durch das Aussetzen der
Wehrpflicht 2011 die Bindung Mensch und
Militär lässt nach das Image meist
schlecht
welchen Ruf hat die Bundeswehr momentan
noch vorher kriegt man aus dem Medien
vor allem mit was alles schief läuft
sage ich jetzt mal gerade im
Beschaffungswesen dass man trotzdem
großzügigen Militärbudget oder einem was
halbwegs gut ist im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern doch nicht ganz so gut
aufgestellt ist
der Kanzler hat die zeitenwände
ausgerufen
Verteidigungsminister und
Generalinspektor müssen sie umsetzen
dafür braucht es eine motivierte und gut
ausgerüstete Truppe Auftrag keine Zeit
verlieren für die zeitenwände sie
brauchen Verstärkung und ich versichere
Ihnen wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck daran
Seitenwände ist im vollen Gange sie
verlangt von uns aber eins noch mehr
Geschwindigkeit die Richtung stimmt die
Geschwindigkeit noch nicht
[Musik]
das ist ein Tempo fehlt das weiß auch
Sie Eva Hügel die werbeauftragte ist zu
Besuch bei der flugabwehrraketengruppe
mit ihren Patch wird luftabwehrsystemen
sind sie im Dauereinsatz seit Putins
Krieg umso mehr sie sollen die NATO
Ostflanke sichern ukrainische Soldaten
ausbilden und auch noch die Heimat
verteidigen dabei fehlt es an Menschen
und Material
wir haben festgestellt dass wir in
gewissen
in gewissen Höhenschichten eine gewisse
Reichweite aktuell keine Fähigkeit
besitzen das ist jetzt nicht von heute
auf morgen passiert ja und dass wir da
so noch so ein bisschen unter ich nenne
es jetzt mal der Friedensdividende der
letzten Jahre zu leiden haben das ist
glaube ich allen bewusst wir hatten
schon vor dem 24 Februar 2022 von allem
zu wenig und jetzt noch viel weniger und
wenn hier in diesem Verband auch
Material abgegeben wurde an die Ukraine
dann fehlt es hier für die Ausbildung
für die Übung und damit für die eigene
Einsatzbereitschaft sprechen sie mir zum
feierlichen Gelöbnis nach ich gelobe ich
gelogen zurück zu den Rekruten in Berlin
der freiwillige Wehrdienst im
Heimatschutz ist der Versuch Menschen
für die Bundeswehr zu begeistern
Nachwuchs und Fachkräfte zu gewinnen vor
allem wenn wie der Krieg herrscht in
Europa
oh mein Gott
derzeit dienen in der Bundeswehr 183.000
Soldatinnen und Soldaten bis zum Jahr
2031 sollen es 203.000 werden es fehlen
also 20.000 in der Truppe hoffen sie auf
Besserung ich wünsche dass das
nachhaltig ist was wir jetzt gerade
erleben und nicht jetzt gerade ein Thema
von Legislatur zu Legislaturperiode wird
das wäre mir wichtig der Befehl zur
Zeitenwende ist erteilt allein die
Umsetzung muss jetzt Ankommen in den
Kasernen und in der Gesellschaft